thank you
[Music]
researchers across the world have
officially run out of things to research
so so parents
parents
are learning to make video calls
to get this chat with other parents
to develop friendships
that Northeastern University researchers
then study
they know how to FaceTime their parent
homes
oh my God I'm not [__] kidding holy
[__] dude can we do a bear video instead
you guys I sent you guys a great very
video recently he's not making it that's
kind of cute though so this is their
pair is FaceTiming another pair wow
that's so cool that's actually really
cute what do they talk about they talk
about loneliness actually I'm not
kidding and religion they talk about
well it keeps things from being lonely
right talk about Bud Light do you think
is that is
did that happen from the pandemic
because you know they were like social
distancing so they couldn't see their
parent friends it doesn't say
um apparently it does say that video
calls could help parents approximate
birds as communication within the wild
which improves their behavior and likely
their well-being in their owners homes
so if they could only like they're not
in the wild right but oh they're used to
being around other parents so if only
they could FaceTime with other parents
then they can kind of get the
approximation of having been around
their own kind and that will help them
be comfortable in their owners homes is
it like is it like Chat Roulette for
parrots so all of a sudden they might be
swiping and there's a parrot jacking off
that's exactly what it's like and that's
what this parrot's saying this parrot
scene another pair it's [__]
the parrots like I didn't want to see
that
person they just wanted to talk yeah he
doesn't look impressed no he doesn't I
just wanted to make friends the research
the researchers have observed how the
birds use the new foundability because
they can choose to do it right if
wondered given the choice would they
call each other uh and the answer which
you can hear apparently in squawks and
head Bobs was a resounding yes some
strong social dynamics started to appear
not only did the birds initiate calls
freely and seem to understand that a
real fellow parrot would be on the other
end wow but but caretakers
overwhelmingly reported the calls as
positive experience for their parents
some caregivers watched the birds learn
skills from their video friends
including foraging new vocalizations and
even learning how to fly wow well they
taught each other how to fly yes so they
just need to socialize more one of the
researchers said that one of the parents
was kind of like being bored all day
came alive during the video calls well
that makes sense otherwise like what the
[__] else are you doing here depression
captivity yeah
so maybe not does that maybe have an
argument for don't keep parrots yeah
maybe do you think Sea World is like why
didn't we
didn't well we should send pairs yeah it
should have been airworld
we have a Sea World already we haven't
seen air world's good it's so it's only
a place where you buy an AC
we need air world the air world is just
all flying creatures flying squirrel
flying parrot flying whatever and
definitely not Bird world how do you
keep it from flying out of here world no
no but then like bigger your dancing
line is so small yeah
up here
and then when they do the show you do
the air show like when they have the the
the the fighter jets yeah yeah you get
the blue angels that you got
the blue get those disasters that happen
too
[__] explosions you get the parents
fly together so close that people like
whoa
no I wanna and then you know how like
they have trainers that fly with the
parrots I want them to get like 2 000
parrots on a string and you see people
holding them like that and flying in the
air with them yeah it's so good just by
the grip of their hand you could buy one
if you want if you could buy one like
balloons yeah balloons but it's like 20
000 parents and then everyone and then
the performers are like yeah and then we
have Eagles so we have the American
Eagles I think like the bomber Jets you
know yeah it's sick what else sick idea
but I wouldn't instead of it being on
the bleachers I would have uh massive
blimps that the audience can go into and
then you go into they got a really good
investment it's like they're in the air
the birds in there that's elevated
everyone see dancers can't even [__]
comprehend like they would be like so
they just not even understand they're
just not really Airborne yeah you would
have to have like one of those like sign
language instructions just to teach
dances like what's going on
and then at the bottom it's all
different bird
we'll call them sanctuaries okay yeah
but it's like the bird cages right and
then you can walk in and then it's like
this is the Asia Sanctuary all the birds
from Asia all the birds from South
America it's all different you know huh
cool yeah
just
this idea his father is his stepdad
so do you want to win this I didn't know
it was a business pitch
um so yeah the birds you know they call
each other now
cool I'm telling you air world I'm
telling you it's a great idea you're
telling me I'm not stopping you you know
what's wrong with the zoo this is this
is one of the biggest issues about the
zoo
they try to do too much [__] they're
like a Chinese Cafe with a [__] 300
people the menu is too big yeah too big
I'll tell you I disagree what do you
think the problem with the zoo is when I
go to the zoo and they're like hey you
see a Jaguar right and then like you
want to buy a turkey leg and I'm like no
I want to buy a Jaguar Lake exactly I'm
hungry but it's that's what I'm that's
my same Market it's not Niche enough
yeah yeah yeah if you're gonna have a
Jaguar have a Jaguar Burger exactly have
a Jaguar stuffed animal that you could
take homework show they're not
maximizing their whole potential they're
not grinding their bones up and turn
them into gelatin enough to make jello
that I take out of a little little cup a
drag that [__] container lid off and
I'm like oh good I'm getting Jaguar
Jello now yep they need to learn from
the Mayans I went to a Mayan town and I
watched a video about mines for 25
minutes yeah in the city of Tulum now
you know all about Mayans and they had a
ancient obsidian Center
where everything was a bit obsidian
obsidian coaster obsidian Arrowhead you
could buy obsidian statue everything
obsidian they knew how to maximize their
obsidian potential yeah but when you go
to the zoo
cockatoo
this thing they don't even have Dolphins
because they're like oh that's aquariums
we don't do that yeah I haven't been in
the zoo in a long time does the zoo
actually serve like different meat at
its food courts no yeah they have cow
they have cow I mean like a burnt dab
Burger they really do have burgers and
chicken at the zoo yeah yeah but they
don't have cows you can't look at them
they have cows and chickens in this wish
they should they serve burgers they have
hot dogs they have chicken tenders even
that kind of feels funny to me dude like
do they have like fish like lunches at
SeaWorld too they have fish sticks no
because that would be slightly awkward
they have but then they're feeding fish
to the actual
animal entertainers the best you can do
is get penguin ribs
ribs yeah they're paper ribs but that's
it that's like that's like going to like
the body's uh experience and then just
eating humans oh oh that's why you can't
do that but I mean we don't really eat
humans though
he says the Japanese guy unless we pay
an exclusive Resort
I mean what's the difference between
that and you go to a Chinese restaurant
and they got an aquarium of all the
things you want to try and you go I want
that crab
restaurant but that's why the Japanese
restaurants are doing right in the zoo
that's true they are have you been to
the tajiki [__] Fish Market you go
there and they go you could get two now
you could get that and then there's like
sushi restaurants right there that's a
fish market yeah they're not teaching
tricks to the fish and stuff right yeah
they're pulling them from the ocean
chopping them up and selling them to
retailers and you eat it all I'm saying
is you can educate while you're getting
fed too
educate Elevate oh you know what they're
so smooth imagine
fried bird at the air show so good fried
just any bird the [__] out of here it's
so good you specifically
so after after they do all the air show
it's kind of like when you go to the
strip club right when they do the you
say the show you're like I like that one
and then you get a lap dance yeah with
it for this one it's like I want a bald
eagle and then they're like all right
would you like it fried steamed what
type and then you're like I wanted Cajun
that's what you do at strip club too you
see the girl you like you [__] fry
her up
culture
[Laughter]
that's cool
but no you get to eat or like [__] and
eat her Bowl yeah
that's what I use it I think we should
do this I think we should do it yeah I
like this air what is it called air
world
set it we said it 17 000 times isn't it
catchy catch it on honestly a hot show
it's awesome I don't know why it's
called the zoo this guy's so [__]
cocky about airworld
you just really think airworld's a good
idea
first of all don't listen to haters
right you want to kill a dangerous
species these guys are so [__] cocky
about your world little do they know it
would be a failure no the government
would crack down on them
foreign
[Music]